لا بالفعل ما زالت المعارك مستعره والقوات
الروسيه تحاول التقدم في جميع المحاور
التي سيطرت عليها في المقاطعه
الثلاثه زبروجه لجانس كودانيت خاصه دانيت
بالفعل هناك محاوله للتقدم في محور باخم
بعد ان السيطره القوات الروسيه الخاصه
قوات فاجنر على مدينه كلشيفكا بالامس
الحديث اليوم عن توسيع الطوق من ناحيه
الشيخ
محاوله التقدم في العمق من الناحيه
الجنوبيه من باخ متعمليات اقتحام للمدينه
من الناحيه الجنوبيه كما ان الناحيه
الشماليه ايضا تشهد تطورات حيث تحاول
القوات الروسيه التقدم من المحورين
يعني من سيدار نحو سيرفس ونحو مدينه باخمه
ايضا هناك محاور كثيره في زاباروجه تقدم
الجيش الروسي حسب المعلومات لدينا هنا
اربعه كيلو مترات وسيطر على بلدتين بينما
يتقدم ايضا في مدينه مارين كان شخصيا كنت
في مدينه مارينكا الليله همم منذ يومين
وبالفعل كانت القوه الروسيه الخاصه تقاتل
عبر اا عبر الشوارع يعني قتال شوارع
بالبنادق الخفيفه بالفعل المسافه قريبه
امتار معدوده ما بين المقاتلين السيطره او
الانسحاب يكون يعني من منزل ومن شقه ومن
مدخل عماره بالفعل حرب شوارع يعني صعبه
جدا في تلك المناطق احمد لكن لابد من
الحديث ايضا ربما يكون همم المشهد هو اكثر
بلاغه من القول هذه هي مشاهد لبعض الاماكن
التي قصفت في مدينه همم دانيتنا هذه هي
مدينه دانيت والقسم متبادل تسقط القذائف
والصواريخ بشكل يومي على المدينه كما ان
الروسيه ايضا تقصف مناطق همم القواعد
الاوكرانيه همم المتاخمه لمدينه دانيت وفي
مناطق مختلفه بالفعل اسفر القصف الاوكراني
عن قتيلين في مدينه مطبيعه هذه المشاهده
التي نتبعها رائد يعني هذه هذه
حتى الان
هذه
متاجر هو السوق كان يعني لبيع همم المواد
الغذائيه وما شابه ذلك بالفعل تم قصف هذا
السوق منذ فتره وهمم هذه الحرائق التي
اشتعلت به اثراء
الصواريخ سته صواريخ سقطت في هذا السوق
منذ ايام بالفعل همم المعارك مستمره
والقذف لا يتوقف احمد ليلا ولا نهارا
تعتبر هذه المنطقه منطقه بنيت من اخطر
واعنف المناطق في العالم خلال همم يعني
الاشهر الماضيه دونا عن الفتره التي
انطلقت فيها العمليات العسكريه لابد من
الحديث ايضا على ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تنفذها جماعه مضاد في محورين اولهما محور
اثبات
دخلت الى منطقه همم
تقترب من الطريق السريع وصفات فتقول
الدفاع بانها همم يعني تقتل
وتنحي المقاتلين الاوكرانيين الذين
يتقدمون في ذلك المحور وتدمر الياتهم
العسكريه كما انهم همم يعني عادوا في
منطقه ابديفكا الجيش الروسي يحاول التقدم
من اطراف افديفك لم يقتحم الضيف حتى الان
يحاول تطويقها وحاول التقدم لكن القوات
الاوكرانيه عادت وسيطرت على نقطتين اطراف
افديتك حسب معلومات خاصه من الجانب
العسكري هنا